hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2016 american fantasy and adventure
movie called pete's dragon
the movie begins with a little boy
called pete who is reading a book about
a lost puppy named elliot while on a
road trip with his parents
suddenly a deer blocks the road and the
car crashes leaving poor pete as the
only survivor
he picks up the book in his bag and runs
deep inside the woods only to be
surrounded by a pack of wolves however
the wolves sent something then become
frightened and back away
pete looks up to find a big green dragon
curious about him instead of going to
eat him
he follows the dragon deep into the
woods
six years later in the small town of
milhaven meacham an old man is telling a
story about how he once encountered a
dragon in the woods
no one believes him as he is the only
one to ever claim to see a dragon but
the story fascinates little children his
daughter grace a forest ranger is not
convinced of a story either and claims
that she has known the forest and
ventures there a lot but has never seen
any dragon
meanwhile in the forest peter is
cheerfully playing with elliot including
a hide and seek game that demonstrates
elliot's ability to turn invisible he
then discovers grace seeking owls in the
woods using her compass and maps
he watches her from afar following her
to an opening where a tractor is left
grace tosses away the tractor's key to
annoy gavin its owner who is an
ambitious lumberjack at night pete goes
to his home in the woods a cave
underneath a big tree where he sleeps
with elliot
the next day pete watches the opening
again observing grace arguing with jack
gavin's brother and also her boyfriend
that they cannot cut down trees in this
area deep inside the forest
jack's daughter natalie is getting bored
of waiting for his father then ventures
outside of her car
she spots a sign of pete gets curious
and follows him into the woods
pete moves fast as he is used to the
forest quickly climbing a tree to get
away from natalie
she tries to climb the same tree but
loses her footing and falls her scream
attracts jack and the woodsman so they
head to the forest and discover pete
grace notices that pete wears the same
compass she lost in the forest yesterday
pete tries to escape them but gavin
accidentally knocks him unconscious
elliott sensing that pete is not nearby
hells to attract his attention but to no
avail
gavin hears elliot's howl and becomes
curious about the sound so he decides to
go hunting
pete is taken to a hospital and
hallucinates going camping with his late
mother the doctors report his good vital
condition to grace who also takes care
of natalie natalie wanders into pete's
room only to find him missing already
escaping through the window
although the police search for him he
manages to outrun them jumping on top of
a school bus until he is cornered at a
high fence
grace catches him and tries to calm him
down but he attempts to escape again and
creates a loud howling sound which
worries her
however she talks to the sheriff to
convince him to not bring pete to the
hospital again but takes him to jack and
natalie's house instead
arriving there pete tries to escape
again into the woods but grace catches
him again pete tells her about elliot
his friend in the woods but when she
asks for more details jack interrupts to
bring them in
pete is mesmerized by the technology and
details of natalie's house while she
patiently explains each thing to him
meanwhile gavin and his men wander deep
into the woods until they arrive at pete
and elliot's treehouse
unbeknownst to them elliott in invisible
mode is following them all along
gavin takes pete's book out of the cave
which angers elliot exposing himself to
the men to scare them off
gavin attempts to shoot the dragon only
to find elliott smashes his rifle like
it is nothing
the men hastily drive off elliot
secretly following them with the hope
that he can find pete back in jack's
house pete finds natalie's storybook
about elliott which is an exact copy of
his then grace asks if elliot is a dog
pete shakes his head but then grace is
interrupted by a call from the sheriff
who dug into old missing person cases
he deduces that pete's family was in a
car crash six years ago and the boy went
missing
the social services wants to take
custody of him tomorrow morning
meanwhile pete is drawing elliot using
natalie's crayons
grace talks to pete privately and she is
intrigued when pete shows her his
drawing of elliot
pete also thinks elliott will like grace
and he is excited to introduce her to
him tomorrow morning
gavin back from the forest knocks on
jack's door
jack does not believe his brother
encountered a dragon and refuses to
wander off to the woods so late at night
gavin leaves while elliott secretly
lands near jack's house
he peeks through a window to see pete
natalie grace and jack are sitting
together the kids listening to jack
reading a story about elliot
elliott is disappointed and returns back
to the woods grace goes to his father's
study to find exact pictures of the
dragon meacham once drew although she
does not fully believe in the dragon she
starts to open herself to opportunities
in the morning grace drives pete and
natalie to the woods with a quick stop
to pick up meacham because she thinks he
also wants to meet elliot
they arrive at the forest and pete leads
the way to his cave
meanwhile jack receives a call from the
sheriff telling him that grace was
supposed to deliver pete to the social
services team already waiting for him
jack deduces grace is going back to the
forest and drives there pete introduces
elliott to shocked natalie grace and
meacham but just as they are about to
embrace elliot gavin and his hunting
party show up to catch elliott thinking
it is a dangerous monster
the event completely destroys pete and
elliot's treehouse and cave
knocked unconscious elliot is brought to
the lumber mill followed by jack grace
and the kids
they secure elliot in a large warehouse
and forbid anyone curious to look at him
from closer
however jack already called the sheriff
and his cavalry to take care of the
dragon
eliot wakes up for a moment and howls
desperately calling pete for help pete
hears elliot and figures out how to help
him with natalie's aid they go out and
look for a secret passage to the
warehouse where elliot is kept
meanwhile gavin and jack hold off the
sheriff who wants to see the creature
while the men are arguing outside
natalie and pete arrive at the warehouse
and lock the door from the inside they
free elliot's chains but elliot is still
unable to fly because of the dizziness
the men successfully break into the
warehouse only to see nothing
however grace knows what is going on she
is the last person to leave the
warehouse after she sees pete and
natalie peeking out from the trailer she
tells jack that the dragon is still
inside making himself invisible
the kids are about to start the trailer
and drive elliott back into the woods
when meacham steps in and offers to help
them drive the trailer they leave the
warehouse leaving everyone puzzled and
scrambling to chase them along the road
jack and grace sheriff and the cavalry
and gavin and his men all pursue the
dragon
gavin almost catches up to elliot but
meacham refuses to pull over
he then blocks the road at the bridge to
force meacham to stop but the trailer's
break fail so meacham has no choice but
to crash into gavin's truck after the
men run away
arriving at the other end of the bridge
elliott finally gathers some courage to
fly on top of the bridge and breathes
fire to scare off the people who have
been bothering him
unfortunately jack and grace are still
trapped inside their car in the middle
of the bridge
the bridge cracks and becomes unstable
falling down on several parts
gavin runs to help save jack and grace
but the bridge's damage spreads causing
more parts to fall off including jack
grace and elliot
meacham pete and natalie watch in horror
and still hoping for a miracle to happen
then elliott comes flying while carrying
grace and jack on his back they regroup
and embrace each other but pete knows
elliot will not be welcomed by the
townspeople he decides to fly off with
elliot leaving grace heartbroken
pete and elliot come back to their
already destroyed treehouse and cave
elliott is saddened by the fact that
even though pete wants to be with him he
will not be safe anywhere near the town
but pete needs a better life there he
urges pete to go back to the town and
live with his own people pointing at an
image in pete's storybook where a family
has happily gathered around the campfire
as sad as he is pete agrees to elliot's
plan
they fly back to jack's backyard just as
jack grace and natalie arrive from the
forest
grace is overjoyed to see pete again
embracing and kissing him with love
jack and natalie are also glad to
welcome pete they hear elliot departs
going far away from the town
sometime later the town seems normal
again although now everyone believes in
dragons so meacham does not have to tell
his dragon stories anymore
jack and grace get married and they
adopt pete
during the holiday they venture to the
north so pete can reunite with elliot
they also watch other dragons fly nearby
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching